we know that Donald Trump is the least
popular president at this point in a
first term since modern approval polling
began we've been following the polling
Trump hit a low of 38 Benny hit a low of
37 then he hit a low of 36 and bounced
back up a little bit and then hit 35 and
34 one poll had Trump at 33% approval we
now have a new poll where Donald Trump
has achieved a presidency low 32%
approval rate this is an Associated
Press NRC Center for public affairs
Research poll it was released Friday and
it found that President Trump has a 32%
approval rating 67% of respondents
disapprove of the job that Trump is
doing the most interesting internal is
that according to this poll only 67
percent of Republicans approve of the
job that Donald Trump is doing that is
very interesting because this means that
if you believe this poll Donald Trump's
down trend in approval is not because
more Democrats now disapprove of Trump
it's not because of more independents
that are now saying they don't approve
of Trump it's because of Republicans
that have moved from being in favor of
the job Trump is doing by about 85
percent down to only 67 percent now
normal caveats this is only one poll you
can always find a poll that shows Trump
doing better a key issue though is that
over time you keep seeing new low water
marks for Trump's approval rating as a
comparison Gallup for example has
trumpet 37% but remember that's plus or
minus three points which could mean that
gallops 37 is really 34 which is not
drastically different than 32%
fivethirtyeight.com has Trump at 38%
approval the real indicator I'm looking
at though is that Republican approval
rating historically mid to high 80s now
the downtick and that has significant
implications number one for Trump 32%
approval might mean hey it's time for
military action it's time for some kind
of belligerence to try to rally people
around him Trump already kind of hinting
about that last week saying hey this
might be the calm before the storm
during a photo op in the White House
with his military leaders may be just
normal Trump bluster but who knows
another implication of Trump's low
approval rating what does this mean for
fellow Republicans and their willingness
to stand up to Trump or tell Trump no or
pursue the findings of the Trump Russia
investigation if they end up being
relevant and lastly what does a 32%
approval rating or a 34 percent approval
rating what needs to happen for that 32
or 34 percent to say I no longer approve
of Donald Trump I don't know what the
answer is at this point if you still
approve of Donald Trump you were either
so ideologically committed to the idea
of Trump that there is nothing he could
do that would make you change your mind
or you stopped paying attention and I
think that that probably is a factor
there are trumpets the same way that
there are anti trumpets who have decided
I approved of the job Trump was doing
three months ago and they've really
stopped paying attention and the news
just doesn't really hit them what people
need to do is get involved in the
midterms and get involved in the 2017
special elections because even at 32%
approval Trump could win reelection and
we need to weaken the Republican Party
as much as possible in Alabama
you've got Doug Jones versus Roy Moore
December 12th I believe special election
get involved Doug Jones was only
something like five and a half points
behind more in a recent poll we're going
to have an upcoming special election for
the now resigned Tim Murphy in
Pennsylvania that's abortion guy who is
pro-life but he tried to force his
presumably pregnant mistress she ended
up not being pregnant to have an
abortion he has now resigned I don't
know when that election will be but it
is upcoming jason Chaffetz has resigned
in Utah there's a general election there
less than a month away November 7th with
six candidates the Republican is likely
to win but it's an opportunity to get
involved anyway so there are
opportunities for you to get involved in
2017 we've got to focus on the midterms
because we don't know that Donald Trump
will be defeated in 2020 we can't count
on Robert Mueller's Russia investigation
so get involved now